20:18 was a pretty rough year for pc
builders at the start of the earth GPU
prices skyrocketed easily exceeding over
$1,000 and once those GPU prices finally
started to come down there was used and
BIA may be launched a new immediate
turing series many people held off on
buying a GPU hoping that this new jury
series would be a lot more worth it
however the cherry trees was a big
disappointment
with the cheapest car coming in at five
hundos going all the way up to twelve
hundred dollars even if you're willing
to pay those high prices these GPUs
weren't really that worth it because the
main technology ray-tracing wasn't even
that good throughout all of this we
didn't see any big GPU launches from AMD
other than the rx 590 but that was just
a minor upgrade over the RX 580 in the
CPU world while AMD is still pushing
forward and offering great CPUs for
outstanding prices we really have no
clue what Intel's doing they literally
just launched another forking animator
series and then they launched a new I 9
series on a mainstream platform called a
97 or ek for over five hundred dollars
and this CPU is quite comparable to a CP
that cost to pretty much half of that
the 2700 when you think that things
couldn't get any worse you realize that
Ram prices have been consistently going
up were yet to pay over $200 for just
sixteen-year bytes of RAM and then you
hear that the three main Ram
manufacturers are the main cost for this
because they have been price fixing for
several years and we're just not paying
the effects of it I think we can all
agree that 2018 was not the best year
for PC builders I'm sure the big
companies can peeled out also especially
in video who lost over half their stock
price in just the last couple of months
2019 on the other hand has a lot of
surprise waiting for us so here's why
2019 is going to be a tremendous year
for PC builders
[Music]
first let's take a look at GPUs the
biggest hassle in 2018 there are some
big GPU launches coming up soon
especially from AMD there have been
countless rumors suggesting that AMD is
going to launch a new high-level GPU
series at the beginning of 2019 and with
aim did not launch any big GPU series in
the past year and a half this does make
sense there is a lot of confusion
whether this new series is going to be
the brand new Navi series on a
completely new architecture or just a
refined video on the new 70-meter
process either way what rumors for both
these series have in common is that
their suggestion that these new series
will be for the average consumer with
that really expensive unnecessary
hardware like ray-tracing
even though AMD is working on that this
series is pretty much supposed to bring
a good boost over the Vega series and
even match some of the art kicked cars
but for a much much cheaper price one of
the most exciting cars to look forward
to is the Oryx 3060 which supposed to
have performance on the level of the art
TX 2070 will only cost half of that at
just $250 so we definitely have some
exciting things to look forward to from
AMD but that's not it for the GPU scene
we also have some things from Nvidia to
look forward to it as well it's been a
couple of months since the arktech
series has launched but there still is
no 60 or 50 series as a result these new
cards should be coming out very soon and
while these cards may not have the best
value especially considering these new
cards these cards will definitely be a
lot more portable options from Nvidia
and options are always good something
that's even more exciting is then video
may even want to fall out 11 on our
series which is pretty much identical to
the 20 series but without ray-traced
technology while this isn't just a rumor
consider the competition room AMD Nvidia
stock price this may very well happen
overall we shouldn't be seeing a lot
more of horrible abuse coming out in
2019 now moving on to CPUs 2018 wasn't
that bad for CPUs because even though
Intel sponsors were more than
disappointing in these launches more
than made up for it with their stellar
second-generation rise in series which
but even more performance for an even
cheaper
however that was just to talk your
upgrade try 19 is that take year where
the huge upgrades gonna be coming out
with 10 - there are some crazy rumors
floating out there suggested to the
writing 7 model will have 12 cores and
24 threads and if there'll be a new
rising 9 model which have 16 cores and
32 threads for a very affordable price
of $500 now while that does sound
amazing
and even if Amy could offer that I don't
think they would please that just
doesn't make any sense because the
mainstream user does not need more than
8 cores and 16 threads at this point
now given that amy has slowly been
increasing at clock speeds of their
octa-core CPU over the past two
generations with the 27 recs being able
to overclock all the way to four point
three gigahertz so what I think we can
expect from AMD especially given the 7in
of architecture which should be a lot
more efficient it's a solid octa-core
processor with 16 threads that is able
to overclock up to 5 gigahertz oh yeah I
almost forgot
you'll also get a nice stock color and
it'll be priced in the mid 300s
now knowing AMD they make completely
blow it out of the water
however I think we constantly expect at
least that from AMD in 2019 and asked
for in tow this may finally be the year
they move on from the 14 interview
process on to the 10 nanometer process
and they finally may offer an octa-core
processor with their eyes segments that
can also hyper thread given all the
competition from AMD
so overall asked for CPUs then to is
absolutely going to kill it make sure to
keep an eye out for thread rubra as well
because last year they double the cores
and threads so I'm pretty sure MB has
something big coming up this year as
well finally
that's for RAM RAM priced have already
settled down pretty much you can get a
16 gigabyte kit right now for $100 which
actually isn't too bad however there is
something very big that may be coming
next year which is b dr v ram no this
does not mean that into a nineteen ddr5
rain will become mainstream and you can
build a pc very soon with VR
Ram however what this does mean is that
sis ddr5 is coming soon made fascist
we'll start to reduce the price of the
are for RAM in order to get rid of their
excess inventory thus during 2019 we
should see RAM prices to continue to
decline and during the highest season of
next year RAM should be offered for
really great discounts overall the
biggest issue that we witnessed in 2018
from PCs was price and in 2019 that
issue should be completely vaporized
really thanks Amy
it's a big competition that they're
going to introduce onto CPU and GPU
market on top of this there are some
very exciting releases coming up very
soon in early 2019 and throughout 2019
as well so while it is unfortunate that
we can all easily agree that 2018 was
not a good year for PCs I think that we
can just as easily agreed that 2019 has
some great surprises which may just
shake up the market but that's pretty
much it as to why 2019 is going to be a
tremendous year for PCs so what do you
guys think are you guys excited for 2019
make sure to post below what you guys
are most excited for also if you guys
like this view that makes you drop a
like and consider subscribing you if you
like to see more videos just like this
one bunt all then I'm Hari I'll see you
guys on next one
[Music]